ccsd students were able to return to
in-person learning and sally jeremiah's
on this story live outside of
john r hummel elementary school with
what parents had to say
about that first day back for ccsd it's
been a long time sally
oh yes brian as you can imagine many
parents told me
they felt nervous others felt extremely
emotional today despite the mixed
feelings
school was great and the bottom line is
that the kids
were happy we were excited to go back of
course a little anxious in
ways and i feel for the teachers kind of
being thrown into
this new harder experience than they've
ever had before jill preston is a mother
of two boys one in second grade the
other in kindergarten
it's been nearly a year that their
morning routine changed now back to
packing lunches and getting the kids
to school my kids were so excited though
and it was so fun to see them
looking forward to doing school preston
says her boys were happy to see their
friends
and teachers in person they got new
backpacks and lunch boxes and got all
their stuff packed in it the night
before
it was pretty emotional for us like me
and my husband when we dropped him off
and watched our little kindergartner
walk all by himself through the gate
eden adrapala says her son was all
smiles
walking into school he mentioned to me
he's like i can't wait to see
my student my student friend because she
never turns on her camera and i want to
see what she looks like
parents tell me they felt safe dropping
and picking up their kids from school
maria salas also glad for the decision
to start school now
it's not just a school district thing i
think it's a community
thing and unified together we can we can
help
our children go back to school we go to
the stores we go
out so why not give our kids an
opportunity
and parents here also told me teachers
communicated via text with them today
which made them feel
extremely comfortable reporting live
sally jaramillo 8 news now